vous Monsieur Le Pen vous êtes classé
dans les extrêmes droites et vous
totalisez 0,20 % des suffrages
c'est-à-dire 25000 voix environ vous
aviez un sortant vous avez un élu et
même si ce score est modeste vous avez
maintenant la parole au nom du Front
national oui permettez-moi d'abord de
combler une lacune de votre revue de
presse je m'étonne de ne pas voir dans
cette revue de presse le quotidien
parisien de droite présent qui paraît
déjà depuis plus de 3 mois et qui donne
en quelque sorte le commentaire des
nouvelles et personnellement je pense
que suggérer à votre collaborateur de le
faire figurer pas seraitotre service
d'abonnement être mal fait la première
fois que je vois ah bon écoutez je pense
que vous êtes mal for mais c'est
probablement toujours cette fameuse
pudeur de la droite et je voudrais
d'abord contester si vous voulez enfin
tout le monde conteste et tout le monde
est content à la fois dans les dans les
journées électorales le chiffre de 0,20
% pour une raison qui est très simple la
droite nationale Front National et
quelques autres mouvement présentai 50
candidats comme tous les petits
mouvements pour des raisons il n'y a pas
de honte à le dire dire strictement
financière puisque nous sommes dans un
dans un pays où seuls les grands partis
ont la chance d'abord de se faire
entendre à la télévision et à la radio
et d'autre part de se voir de se voir
rembourser leur campagne n'est-ce pas ce
qui n'est pas le cas des petits
mouvements qu' soient d'ailleurs de
gauche ou de droite et bien évidemment
quand on compare 50 candidatures à 2000
circonscriptions on arrive à des
chiffres en fait et je me permets de
citer mon quotidien habituel je constate
que par exemple euh nous avons fait à
dans la Drome 6 60 % euh dans l'iser un
de nos candidats 10 34 à Dreux
1277 adreux encore 936 où le maire
madame Gaspard perdra probablement sa
mirie l'année prochaine deux autres
encore dans dans dans ce département 55
et et et 530 par conséquent les
candidats du Front national ont des
raisons de se satisfaire comme tout le
monde de ses résultats électoraux il
donne la consigne pour le 2è tour de
voter bien sûr contre les candidats de
la majorité ceci cette nuance pour
permettre éventuellement des votes pour
des divers gauches divers gauches
antimarxistes que nous n'avons a priori
aucune raison de battre particulièrement
bien Monsieur Le Pen je vous remercie il
est 13h05 je referme ce dossier
politique G